ladies and gentlemen
here is something that you have never
heard me say
this is by far the
juiciest podcast we have recorded to
date it almost no it didn't almost it
totally made me like
uncomfortable it was so juicy and there
may be certain parties that want to
reach out and get on the podcast to
respond that
is all i'm saying let's get into this
crazy
stuff ladies and gentlemen
ethan klein yeah hello
dude hey i don't know if you've ever met
my co-host
scott randolph how's it going i haven't
met scott but i've been talking to
embrace before the show
good conversation about your rv
uh sewer system being full i don't know
if you call it a sewer system that might
be
it's called it's a tank of urine a black
black tick correct
and coming from off camera who you won't
see but that's a pisser because he is
good looking
the gorgeous paul briskey what's up
ethan how are you
i see him are you oh yeah i'm in the
chat oh how about that
that's quite a chance i see him good
looking
speaking of seeing have you ever seen
such a [ __ ]
crisp and beautiful picture on a zoom
call
never before in my life i i'm gonna
answer that
affirmatively yes i feel like you set me
up you want me to say
no yeah but you have definitely never
because
dude i got on a zoom call the other day
a pretty random one with the world
famous
photographer atiba and all of a sudden
i'm like wait wait hold on a second
t but dude what the [ __ ] going on i
like
he says i plugged in my dslr to zoom
so you've got this unbelievable great
picture
like i'm like dude the world is all on
zoom calls
nobody knows that you can plug in a
professional camera
to a zoom call it's probably why their
stocks rising so much just because
they're epic
i don't know but uh yeah zoom has
definitely got a quarter
actually you know what i'm saying i'm
sorry i can't i cannot tell
why i have seen better i called
i had a i had a zoom call with the
president of shopify and i was floored
by the quality and he told me the same
thing he said i'm using a dslr
mirrorless and that's the first time i
learned you could do that
and i am sad to tell you this is only
the second best picture i've seen
what were you doing on the call with the
shopify dude we love talking about merch
oh he was uh he wanted to you're just
talking shop you know a couple big wigs
yeah you got all those products behind
you i see the shirts lined up and the
paint
this is our we have a teddy fresh our
whole uh years
line plan this is on this side you can't
see but it goes every month december
january or february
this is march april
dude that is the way that's the way you
do it he says that's january that's
straightforward
they're putting out all new products
every month every month you're doing
that
yeah we have monthly drops wow you have
teddyfresh.com
his son is named theodore nice yeah it's
not related though because that makes us
look weird but
it's not related she's using your kid
teddy fresh was before theodore
oh so theodore's maybe named after the
merch
yeah well he's not but it looks like he
is and it's
kind of embarrassing are they limited
drops these monthly jobs that's my
question
great question paul thanks dude are they
are they what limited
some people know that like supreme like
you gotta buy it now or you'll never be
able to get it again
yeah it's all new stuff we occasionally
if there's a style that hits really hard
we'll restock it but for the most part
it's you know it's lim
it's limited because i think the
creative process
you know you want to keep creating and
uh people like to see new stuff so the
monthly new drops
are um are fun and exciting
how many how many units do you drop like
per
shirt oh we're getting into it it
depends it depends
it depends okay this is like a shark
tank question
yeah exactly what's your mark what's
you know it's so cool the way that i met
ethan i i
uh one night i forget one video
led to another video i went down a
youtube rabbit hole
i'm like what's this [ __ ] h3h3 [ __ ] i
love it man it's like the [ __ ]
internet police
busting kooks for faking pranks and
stuff
and i'm like dude this is great so then
i just went ahead and i got on twitter
and i was like yo i just i tweeted i
just became a huge fan
of h3h3 yoe then what's up
and like in in short order ethan hit me
back
i was like man this is the way to like
you know network and meet cool celebrity
friends yeah
yeah i had never done that before i
don't think so then he hit me back we
exchanged cell numbers
we got together i remember the first
time that we met in person i drove out
to his house
and uh and and we were talking about
youtube and all the
fake pranks was a topic of conversation
and i was like man there were these two
guys
who were very established youtubers who
who
helped collaborate with me to launch my
channel
you know like i'm gonna film with them
on their channel they're gonna drive to
my channel
it's gonna be great and and so we're
figuring out what are we gonna film i
don't
go film a prank you know and they're
going to think well
what's the prank gonna be and they're
like oh man we can just fake it and i
was like
what yeah it's like what yeah exactly
like i'm like dude
i said you guys don't [ __ ] understand
if i fake one
[ __ ] thing ever then all of the
things i've ever done in my career come
into question there's absolutely no way
would
ever [ __ ] fake were they
we can't say any names i think that like
anybody could look at at how i launched
my channel
i mean and plus it was a [ __ ]
vitality okay
yeah he's admitted he has since admitted
that some of his pranks were fake so
there's okay
yeah well it was a really big topic on
youtube was all these dudes started
faking their pranks and um everybody
knew it but it's funny because vitaly
always held like on the original pre
you seen his crazy coke-filled uh grant
that that was like oh my god it was
pretty great yeah
he says like and he's like like five
other videos i've ever made were fake
yeah it's one of my favorite videos
ever dude it's oh he name drops to you
he goes uh
wrote me a letter and he says that he
loves me and he was like so none of
y'all [ __ ] [ __ ] can say [ __ ] i i
do
i do remember that what it was was like
he had just gotten in the ring with the
ball
and the ball broke his jaw oh yeah
that's right and i
and i was like what and i i remember i'd
tell you it's pretty good
yeah i tensioned him i was like dude
with the [ __ ] bull dude i was like
battalion you're the real deal
so he takes he takes a fake bowl
he i i i think that's what it was i
texted him yo
you're the real deal because he got in
the [ __ ] with the bull yeah and then he
says
you see stevo says i'm the real deal
like as if it was a comment about his
pranks being real
yeah yeah yeah that's awesome yeah was
that you that called out that one dude
that was like going up to random chicks
and like
it's been like yeah you want to make out
dude prank convince yeah
yeah yeah yeah prank invasion i have a
long
and colorful history with prank invasion
uh he's a great one he
he did famously mommy make out day on
vintage i loved that video
god i loved that video so much then
there was the the legendary joey salads
i think what's most incredible about
about ethan here is that
he'll just eviscerate destroy
these these youtubers but then like
turn around and have him on his podcast
and they're growing down
yeah that's a pretty impressive talent
to be able to
essentially destroy somebody's
livelihood and then have a laid-back
conversation with them on your
podcast well i hope i'm not destroying
their livelihood but
i know what you mean they're not like
friendly videos but i agree i mean i
like meeting people
the person that they are because you
know ultimately they're just
dudes for the most part like most of
these guys i met are really
good normal dudes vitaly you know he
he's an exception obviously he just beat
the [ __ ] out of some random woman and
he's in jail and [ __ ]
and floyd's crazy oh [ __ ] yeah didn't he
but like for the most part
he's an outlier yeah he should be he
should be
he beat the [ __ ] out of her dude you
didn't see that on tv i saw that but i
didn't know how real it was oh my god no
it was real
he beat up he beat up a woman allegedly
he allegedly beat up a woman like really
and he's got
you think that the the one cook field
like
uh calling out the fake pranks video or
whatever it was was gnarly
he's got the most legendary mug shot of
all time why what is it oh my god
he got down oh dude it's just yeah he he
he
allegedly you know the stories he went
into a roid rage
and he started beating the [ __ ] out of a
random woman
so she got like decimated he's [ __ ]
jacked
too like he can do some damage yeah he's
like
but anyway most people everyone but
vitali why is my siri keep going off
what is this
sorry these are last things
i've reached that point of uncomfortable
where we're talking negatively
i mean i think okay but it wasn't i was
about to talk positively
yeah okay good so i was gonna say with
the exception of a tally
everybody just said he's going to come
kill me now
yeah he's going to be fresh out of jail
he's going to stab you everybody
else who's come through which is most of
the pranksters we've talked about
end up being really sweet we have good
rapport and we have great conversations
you know so
so um joey salt is a really nice guy
like i text with him
he's [ __ ] dumb as hell but i say that
to him he's like the dumbest person man
yeah
but he's super sweet and he wouldn't
take offense to that there's definitely
uh a correlation like
between stupidity and sweetness
like a puppy dumb people can be
really lovely i think there's it's more
common the dumber the nicer right
that's probably true yeah it's like
almost like a child like
demeanor i'll tell you intelligence is a
[ __ ] liability i used to say this all
the time
you know like uh history what do we know
about history
the [ __ ] [ __ ] repeats itself it's all
bad news and it's definitely gonna
repeat itself
so the more you know the more bad news
you know
the more [ __ ] the intelligence gets
you nowhere
except it makes you miserable ignorance
is bliss
it really is no it really is you know
and they say
they say that the more intelligent
people are more prone to depression
they do say that yeah i don't know who
they are and i don't know where they
said it i think they tried that once
are uh tend to be smarter mm-hmm um
so so i met up with ethan and it was
great like we had to wait a real good
laugh we're
you know i remember this i believe that
that was
2017 when uh ethan and i hooked up
we had a little bromance going we made a
youtube video
i haven't particularly thought it was so
funny smash the like button
we got into this whole thing kind of
smashed that like button
so hard and yeah being desperate for
likes like uh
yeah i couldn't quite understand the
whole thing
you know i felt like i still feel like
i'm a youtuber but kind of looking at
youtube from a little bit of a
of a side perspective but um we made a
youtube video
which got demonetized where
we made like a ball a fake ball sack
which was actually filled with blood and
i pulled it out of my
jeans and like with the scissors cut off
the balls i got all these bloods going
it was like it was pretty evidently fake
it was super fake but youtube doesn't
[ __ ] around with that kind of stuff
and well i'm happy to say i don't i
don't know of any other
mainstream youtube video where someone
gets castrated like that
yeah groundbreaking right and i think it
was
yeah whatever and now the video that
that was in
was like one it was like a pretty
serious topic it was uh
the family of five or whatever like this
daddy the kid was flinching at the
person yelling oh that [ __ ] was awful
yeah daddy of five
did can you give us an update on what
happened with the the daddy of five
folks
now i did say that certain parties could
be on the podcast to respond
but daddy of five is not one of those
parties
i'm not interested in having them on
okay but what i am interested in
is telling you guys from my heart
how much i appreciate you and
how much i appreciate the sponsors of
this show
i mean particularly manscaped who
actually encourages me to tell you
that they are going to make your hole
look great and they're not even beating
around the bush they're beating it down
that's the bush around your butthole
that's the bush around your balls
and they like that i talked that way
okay and now we got the holiday season
here and so what's going on
guess what manscaped is claiming
the most wished for gift by men yeah
what is it it
is the ultimate package the ultimate
hygiene bundle the performance package
from manscaped
it's going to give you everything you
need
to stay on top of your grooming except
maybe the
eyebrows okay that's wax and
i'm not talking about it but i am
talking about manscaped it is
time to hurry up and get these gifts
shipped
so get on over to manscaped.com
stevo that's going to get you 20 off
your order
and free shipping come on dude
get the gifts get it for yourself stay
on top of it
the ultimate performance hygiene
package for men okay one last time 20
off your order and free shipping go to
manscaped.com
stevo now let's hear what happened to
this family
oh yeah you know what um he made i think
he made a new channel called
hold on he made a new channel i think
he's back on youtube
and it's called it's called daddy on his
own because
i swear to god i swear to god hold on
daddy five new channel daddy 05
were there not criminal charges brought
against them
yeah no they got they got totally uh he
lo i
i think he lost his kids some of his
kids
and god i don't remember but yeah he
he definitely got in trouble with the
law see i'm seeing daddy
the martin boys looks like he changed
the channel name he's back
the martin boys yeah that was it i if i
recall correctly it was the mom
who was more abusive they were both
shitty people
and that that was just one of the you
know youtube goes through these peaks of
and valleys of uh tremendous
fads and that was one of the weirder
ones was abusing your kids
for youtube views which was one of the
more interesting fads i've witnessed on
youtube and i'm glad we were there
to comment on it did he get in trouble
because you commented on it
like did you expose that i wasn't the
only one i was far from the only one
philly d was the one that was really
going in on him and he and they had like
beef it was pretty really dude
yeah philip defranco was kind of the
spearhead of that movement yeah you're
in the community
yeah dude um so like if
your videos have essentially like taken
on you know like to
you're like the internet police you're
busting people for being
shitty people and and doing wrong things
like if that's had a detrimental effect
on the subjects of your videos
probably the higher end of the
detrimental effect would be daddy of
five so i participated
in probably the most destructive h3h3
videos as that's safe to say
the most destructive yeah what's the
most destructive
well you know let's see i mean yeah the
family was broken up but
again i don't i don't know that we can
take credit right credit but we could
certainly
we can but again this guy was really
abusive and it was a terrible situation
so
so you know what about the most what's
the most damage i've ever done
hmm well i got in a lot i got in a like
two year long lawsuit with the guy
did you win that yeah i won which one
was that or can you talk about it that
last year i could talk about it cool
because well he wanted to settle after
two years and getting his ass kicked in
court
and i mean we spent like a quarter
million bucks
uh lawsuits are such a [ __ ] nightmare
but right huh
after beating his ass in court he goes
he goes okay i'll drop the lawsuit if
you agree
not to talk about me in public and we're
like [ __ ] you dude i'm gonna
there's no way that i'm gonna go through
this and not talk about you because we
were threatening
to counter sue him for attorney fees uh
which had about
i i think about like a 60 to 70 percent
chance of succeeding
like he didn't have any money in england
if you
if you win your lawsuit it's automatic
you're the other person has to pay your
that's why nobody [ __ ] sues anybody
in england that's not true
oh in england in england oh wow
in england you automatically have to pay
your [ __ ]
the other that's crazy how do you know
that because my dad [ __ ] lived in
england like i
understand this to be true if you're
gonna sue somebody in england you better
have your [ __ ] ducks in a row because
if you lose
then then you have to pay their [ __ ]
legal fees i like that well i think
that's
i think that's really smart because
there's so much frivolous lawsuits and
there's no repercussions for wasting so
much time
and you know the process of recovering
your funds is a whole nother lawsuit
that's going to cost you another hundred
thousand dollars
right and be super tedious and take
months and months of time you know
um it that seems to have been resolved
fairly recently right because i i
seem to think the last time you brought
that up
you said it was still ongoing is that
right no it ended it ended
a couple or three two or three years ago
but anyway he said but i said we're not
we're not going to agree not to talk
about it i want i'm going to be able to
say whatever i want about it or
or we'll continue the lawsuit and so he
his lawyer convinced him to
to drop it so wow he dropped the case
and i can talk about him but
the whole case was just such [ __ ]
like the guy
just to give some context so i don't
seem like a total [ __ ]
like we made a reaction video to this
guy and he said yo you have to pay me
eight thousand dollars or i'm gonna sue
you and we're like well you know [ __ ]
you
eight thousand oh it's fair use it's
it's fair use you know what i mean it's
like it
it's legal what i'm doing it's
transformative and so he sues us for
copyright infringement
um and it was just a really brutal
vindict
he throughout the whole process he was
like okay
you need to promote me apologize
publicly
and pay me ten thousand dollars it was
always like this escalating
ridiculous requests to humiliate us and
and like he had done this to other
creators so this is a guy who whenever
he's made fun of because he made really
goofy
silly kind of videos and our video about
him wasn't really that bad to be honest
it was pretty light-hearted and fun
but uh he was super vindictive and he
thought he could easily just come and
come and stomp on us and and silence our
free speech and our
fair and our right to legal fair use and
so
ultimately he sued us for copyright
infringement and um
over the course of like two years was
just
the most miserable brutal part
you know two years of my life but but
you know we won we run
we won resoundingly and now the lawsuit
is actually
um is a case file you can go to
fairuse.gov and it's one of the
landmark fair use cases and the only one
by the way
on youtube where a creator has won a
precedent a strong president for fair
use so it was a really important actual
legal case
super cool i remember when i found out
about fair use dude my head exploded i
was like oh my god because i was
just in the midst of putting together a
comedy special where i was going to use
footage to illustrate
the stand-up comedy act what's the
what's the comedy special it's called
gnarly and where can they get that it's
available at stevo.com
right and i've seen it it's very good
thank you man thank you so much
i thought that i was gonna have to
[ __ ] like license every clip
from like mtv comedy center you know
like and and they're like i find out no
it's fair use dude and so somebody
hooked me up with the clearance attorney
who
reviewed it and made an opinion letter
and with
that uh legal support um
you know i was able to get insurance for
it so if we ever get in trouble can we
be like
to the judge can we be like you know i'd
like to refer to the h3h3 versus the
youtube community guidelines case
and that like yeah it's illegal it's a
legal question so if there was a fair
use
elite court battle like when when they
were writing up papers
and all the documents with super tedious
long-winded
legal arguments they were they're always
citing different presidential cases and
so now ours is in that lexicon
it's pretty happy and it's a really
important one that a lot of people will
cite
for anyone listening who doesn't know
what is fair use like what exactly are
we talking about
so fairies is a legal doc doctrine in
the united states specifically
each country has their own version of
fair use that says that
you can use someone else's content that
they
own for criticism commentary
newsworthy uh stuff that that's valuable
to the public discord
so that you know it's a really important
doctrine because it means you don't
need someone's permission to criticize
them or
if there's information like in stevo's
case that has historical
relevance or information that's that
contributes to the public discourse you
don't need to license
that information or or they can or not
even license but they could just say no
you can't use it
so it's a very important legal doctrine
that basically uh
you know helps bolster freedom of speech
and and creativity and art yeah like for
example if i'm going to provide
insight and a new perspective that's
factually correct and informative and
beneficial to the public
about the the intricacies of how mike
tyson broke my [ __ ] nose so
dramatically badly
it's damn right you're going to see mike
tyson break my nose
and who wouldn't want to see that at
stevo.com
yeah i mean the most important thing
about uh fair use is that it's
transformative so
yeah they can't they they determine is
this competing
with the original art in its in its
native marketplace so if it's siphoning
off like that that's one of the
strongest indicators and so
they go well are you just are people
just watching your video as a substitute
for the original well then that's not
fair use you know you're just stealing
business
making fun of his video are not watching
it as a substitute for his video they
would never watch his video because they
don't
they don't find it entertaining
in the very nature of my video
can i make a video analyzing you
analyzing somebody else that's all fair
use right
yeah yeah yeah you know like
it depends obviously you know has age 38
we could make a video saying hey in this
case we love
ethan but we think that he might have
gone a little bit too hard on this
person so let's look at what he
did let's provide i would love that
video too
you could theoretically uh make that
video sure yeah
but like you know if it's just you
watching the video silently for
for the entirety of it and then you're
like so
that concludes my video that's not fair
use right
that's just uh reproduction
and distribution exactly stevo
right that's pretty good so uh okay now
when we began our bromance and i believe
it was 2017
um i remember i think that you were just
getting ready to start the podcast but
you had not started the h3 podcast
yet and uh and and i was
doing stand-up and i was like yeah man
i love doing stand-up comedy man it's
really i've kind of figured out my own
approach and you were like dude i think
the podcast is gonna kill it you should
be doing the podcast
you started the podcast and you were
trying to get me
you were encouraging me to do a podcast
while i was encouraging you to do stand
up
right i remember yeah did you ever uh
give it a shot did you no i'm not
interested because
it's a for it's a whole new discipline
um that i just i'm not i'm not prepared
i'm not good at
and it's just i like what i'm doing
and you know i just and also like who i
i mean i don't know that i'm that funny
to be up on the stage just doing schtick
you know i mean uh
i think that you would i think that you
would find your way
with uh the touring it's it's a little
bit of a grind
where you're always traveling you're
always
a day kind of very unattractive the
traveling and stuff you know
if you want to make it as a stand-up
comedian you gotta hit the road
a lot pretty much yeah i mean i love it
and i've always been kind of a
nomadic like you know always wanted to
be a rock star and the idea if i'm on
tour it was always really sexy to me
you know uh but um
and it's fine but now the podcast
just changed everything for you right is
that fair to say
yeah the podcast was really great for us
because
it gave us stability um
like you know with the h3 production
videos it was always kind of
uh you never knew where your next
meal was coming you never knew where
your next great video was coming from
because
you were kind of always just reacting to
what was in the world
sometimes the world just wasn't that
interesting right and so
the podcast gave us a way to you know
pitch a tent
and and just have knowing that we're
gonna be doing something every week
every week so that was really good and
the other really great thing that came
out of the podcast was the
collaborative nature of like we've hired
this whole crew that we love and we work
with and
has really enriched my life and my
creative uh
expression i really like working with
them which is something i never did
based on h3
how many people well on the podcast
we've got
uh zach ian dan and a.b so there's four
guys who are like cast members crew
members
and uh it's really fun you know it's
it's fresh
it's fun it's different and i feel like
i really needed to be doing something
different because i was getting kind of
burned out
wait which guy which guy on your podcast
was it that was
really gushing about how he just
couldn't believe how much he enjoyed
my comedy special which is called gnarly
at stevo.com
i mean he that [ __ ] blew his mind what
did he say he
do you remember right he's like dude
well i don't know if you're kidding or
not but zach did do that
he really did we're just shamelessly
promoting yeah
i know you're promoting but zach did
really love it
thank you what did he love which part
exactly
i'm not zach unfortunately now uh to
give perspective on this because i feel
like i really have like
you know firsthand experience with this
because when
when you and i met we're hanging out we
made this video
the fact that the the fake ball sack
coming out of my jeans
with all the fake blood the fact that
that video got demonetized
really affected you you were like [ __ ]
there was this d
and then and then at that same sort of
moment in
youtube there was what was called
adpocalypse is that right like
where they found like super like hateful
content
like associated with certain brands and
then the brands were like yo
youtube you just put my uh you just put
my coca-cola ad on like
some kind of isis they put it on isis
videos are they really
yeah and then all of a sudden all of a
sudden like youtube youtube
put it on terrorist propaganda videos
and coke was like dude
i don't even know if it was cooked but
but you know just said it was yeah it
was it was like pepsi
coke it was how does isis have a youtube
channel like they have a lot of subs
it was kind of a w like looking back
pre-adpocalypse
youtube was a pretty wild place isis had
a youtube channel and they had vid
and ads on it dude it was called isis
right coca-cola
was directly funding terrorism through
this dude
was there a youtube channel called isis
i don't [ __ ] know no it was called
like
uh you know what if i even joke i'm
gonna come out like an [ __ ] but it
wasn't called isis
so youtube can kind of over correct you
know
like youtube takes the the stance of
like all right if it's
even remotely in question it's
demonetized sure very broad strokes
and at that time i remember ethan as
well as like a whole bunch of youtubers
like really like feeling the squeeze you
know it was like wait a second oh yeah
you know like back then our
we were making like 100 of our income
was from
youtube revenue which is really dumb
you're like it's really not well
diversified
but we didn't we were just like happy
with it you know our adsense was good
and we were happy with it
and so all of a sudden the adpocalypse
comes about and i would say 90
of our income disappeared in you know
one day
wow so which is kind of insane because
we let's say we're making like a hundred
thousand dollars a month
in that sense we're stoked on it's good
money and then also we're making
and then all of a sudden we're making
ten thousand which is a lot of money
but like you have employees you have
a house that you're renting with the
assumption that you're making
a hundred thousand dollars a month and
ten thousand dollars a month isn't
enough to pay the [ __ ] bills that you
have
when you go when you lose that much
income so it was a big uh
kind of a panicky situation for us how
long did it turn out correct
turn turn he's trying to the podcast
that was the crash
why the podcast was the correction
honestly they're still correcting it
but but it's gotten much better
obviously back then it was just like
everybody's just yellow yellow yellow
yellow unless you're making like uh
minecraft content for kids you know that
makes me really interested
to to ask you about
about adsense because in my
view like like with this podcast channel
on youtube right with the podcasts
i think we started out and i was like
[ __ ] that because we've got
sponsors that pay for ad reads so i
don't want the
the companies that are paying me to read
an ad to like to go check the
podcast and then it starts off with all
this adsense youtube videos i feel like
if i was the
sponsor i'd be pissed about that be like
what the [ __ ] are these ads doing
on the podcast i paid for being a part
of so
yeah they don't care though we started
out
we started out with no ads no ads at all
but then but then the views like went
down and i thought oh
[ __ ] this is a problem because now
youtube is not has no incentive
because the ads are turned off youtube
isn't going to promote the video
like because there's nothing in it for
youtube so i thought
[ __ ] we got to turn the ads back on just
to get so
there's a balance between alienating the
viewer with ads
and alienating youtube with not right
where
where do you find that sweet spot as far
as i can tell
what youtube says and from my empirical
uh
experience is that ads don't affect
viewership so sometimes it can seem like
it
but it i don't think there's any
connection between turning ads off and
lower viewership although sometimes you
know
it's hard to tell because sometimes you
see that correlation but
um you put as many [ __ ] ads as you
want nobody cares
really wow man because out of like love
and respect
for my viewers i've disabled every mid
role
i i will not have unskippable ads only
skippable no [ __ ] banners
[Laughter]
you know back in the day they had like
30 second unskippable ads
they they could they stop that they do
like seven second unskippable ads down
and they're they're pretty palatable
honestly um i feel like every
youtuber in the beginning i used to do
that back in the day because i was like
i just i want my art you know you think
but people people
it's just commonplace right everybody
accepts that there's ads on youtube and
more than that people want to support
you they want you to make money right if
they like your content because they're
watching ads everywhere else on youtube
they honestly don't even notice that you
don't have ads
they don't even notice right i mean
that's great because it's worth it to me
to pay 9.99 a month to not have any
[ __ ] ads yeah i don't know i
i don't remember i do that too i i have
youtube premium
i think it's a great service because you
get the music too so it's it's really
a nice service but um
but people don't notice and now our our
adsense on the podcast and our podcast
highlights channel is is quite a
substantial amount of money
so i definitely wouldn't turn those off
all right man i'm i appreciate that
input i was i was looking to ask that
question and by the way i think this
podcast is wildly [ __ ] entertaining
i love it i really think this is a good
podcast man thank you for
for uh this opportunity ethan um you're
welcome
thank you for inviting me you said
something interesting you were like man
back then
it was only adsense revenue and i i'm
it seems so obvious that to have a
gigantic social media following
whether it's on youtube or any other
platforms or all of them put together
that the following in and of itself is
kind of like having a store
with a lot of traffic coming through but
if you don't have anything on the shelf
then you're not selling anything who
cares how much foot traffic you're
getting
you gotta have something on the shelf
and i remember when we met
i was asking you about your how you do
your merch
and i seem to recall that you were like
oh well we've got this one-stop shop
they print the shirts they you know like
cut me a check of a licensing type thing
yeah and i was telling you back then i
was like oh dude you should talk to
scott because scott
kind of puts it together himself where
like all we
have a just a fulfillment center but
they're not you know
yeah it seems like you're doing that now
right did you make the shift from doing
that on some other platform to like
selling your own [ __ ] how do you fulfill
your orders
yeah so well now teddy fresh we have
over 20 employees
and we have a building we basically
we do everything ourselves we have a
design department a production
department
we have a fulfillment service so we have
a fulfillment service here in la
that does our fulfillment they're really
good i wouldn't want to do it myself
honestly because
maybe you save a little bit of money but
like these guys who do the fulfillment
are really good at it
and the logistics of of storing and
shipping and doing all that [ __ ] is like
a monster so i leave that part to the
pros
but yeah we have a design team and we
have a production team
we have all these ven i mean it's a
full-fledged fashion company at this
point when you say production teams so
you
they're doing all the silk screening
they're actually printing the shirts in
your no
what that means is that we have a
production team who
so the production team basically is
manages like the tech pack the technical
packs that we send to our uh
manufacturers
so the design team makes a design and
they hand it off to the production team
who specs it out into a production a
tech pack
pack is right behind you right sorry to
cut you off this isn't a tech pack but
this
this is just our line sheet but a tech
back is a very technical where it says
like
how big all the buttons are and how big
the hems are and how thick the
what kind of heavy the fabric is and
every single possible detail so
you send those to the manufacturers uh
and so they know you know the more
detail the better and
they send they they make it to spec
they send you a sample and then from
there the production team
works with the manufacturers you get a
sample sample sample you keep
tweaking it making it perfect so that's
kind of what the production team does is
working
directly with the manufacturer what's
your best seller
shirts or beanies by our hoodies by far
are our best sellers for sure beanies do
good
but um hoodies are just really in style
right now i think
too so it's kind of a fad you've
considerably stepped up your merch game
dude that's great i remember
asking david dobrik i was like david
dobrik
like i just watched your [ __ ] my
mansion video
like they're [ __ ] giving away all
these cars where
where do you get all your [ __ ] money
and he goes like uh he's like he says
merch i remember
i was like is it adsense is it says he
says
he says it's merch is my his main
revenue stream
and uh yeah that's yeah yeah yeah
for sure you know david dobrik's super
popular that guy that guy has got
he's got a lot of revenue streams at
this point but back when i met him
a few years ago he kind of was one of
the first people i saw
that was really doing the merch [ __ ]
like crazy and
him and logan paul the jake brothers
were kind of the first people to
uh show everybody what was possible in
the merch
department you know was that right after
adpocalypse that they started going
so hard with the merch or were they
already doing that i think they were
already
doing oh nice and i was just so focused
on content i
i really wasn't business-minded i was
just like really enjoying making videos
and growing the channel and all this but
once on
apocalypse hit you know we had to really
[ __ ]
figure it out but it was good it was
good in the end because we made the
podcast which is super stable
we have ads uh and
you know and then we made teddy fresh
which has been a labor of love honestly
since the beginning but
it started to become our main uh
uh income source for sure over the past
year
and you've been just utterly [ __ ]
pandemic proof uh because
every single revenue stream you have is
unaffected by coronavirus is that right
that's right we've been really fortunate
in that sense we've moved the podcast
into our basement
we have a podcast studio the same one
you remember we moved into our basement
we gutted that whole place and uh
teddy fresh all of our employees are
working from home for the most part
because we just don't want to risk
anyone get infected but
our business hasn't dipped at all the
teddy fresh because
in fact you could even argue it's gone
up because people are not going to malls
they're not going shopping but they
still want to buy [ __ ] they're still
getting money
not i mean there's a lot of people that
have good jobs who are working from home
and they're not spending as much money
as they used to going out to movies
going to malls going on vacation so
they're buying [ __ ] online
so we've been really really fortunate
that our businesses haven't been
now when you say that you moved the
podcast into the basement
is that the basement at your house and
did i see something did i
do i remember seeing like a headline
like
like ethan's got a 9 million dollar
house was that
is your house 9 million bucks spoiler
alert he corrects me
it's 9.1 million dollars
i can't even imagine living in a house
worth 9.1 million dollars
but who cares because look at that 9.1
million dollar chunk of puss in my bed
yeah and it is with great
joy that i tell you about the sponsor
for this little bit it's hellotishie.com
the bidet
that you use to blast all the poop off
your butthole after a sloppy dump
right it's like cleaning your ass with a
pressure cleaner and
i just love it so much check it out last
night i blasted my ass and then i
felt so good so satisfied with the dump
i just took
that i went ahead and forgot to flush
yeah so my girl she
she just takes a picture of my poop she
says thanks for flushing dude
i'm like you know what sorry i just felt
so
satisfied after my poop because when
you're using hello tushy
you know you get just a full
poop and then you'd blast your butt you
twist the knob
and it is so
satisfying you grab some toilet paper
mostly just to dry off your [ __ ]
you know and to enjoy the satisfaction
of seeing that there's no poop on that
paper
i'm telling you i shouldn't say this but
i will hello tishi
is my favorite product that we have ever
promoted
on this podcast that's how much i love
it
and i know you're going to love it just
as much so you need to go to
hellotushy.com
stevo that's going to get you 10 off
your order
plus free shipping one more time 10 off
and free shipping if you go to
hellotushy.com
stevo now let's hear about this
obnoxious house
well stevo was actually 9.1 but
really yeah we have a nine million
dollar house
wow what is a nine million dollar house
feel like
it feels like i'm [ __ ] rich bro
good for you i mean look yeah congrats
[ __ ] uh yeah it's in the basement of our
house we have this whole big like
recreation area in the basement
that we've converted to a full-on
production area we have three sets down
there
i mean it's crazy look i mean you know
three years ago we
we we were not even worth a million
dollars probably
and so yeah it's we've had a really good
past couple years and uh yes stevo i am
very [ __ ] rich
dude congratulations brother i've been
trying to figure this out for a long
[ __ ] time because i
have a strong ass work ethic okay
i've never been [ __ ] lazy i i do not
ever stop i am just [ __ ] the most
hustling ass
constantly [ __ ] working and i seem to
work a lot
[ __ ] harder than my income reflects
well we need some people that are like
famous on youtube and facebook and
they're like you know like yeah i made
like a hundred thousand dollars this
facebook video you're like
what you made a hundred thousand dollars
on one video like
facebook money is insane i'm not getting
any facebook money i [ __ ] hate
facebook
i hate mark zuckerberg i hate everything
those [ __ ] do but
somehow and it's all the pranksters and
all the really shitty weird content
that is killing it on facebook making
like
insane insane money joey salads has like
a video on facebook that made like 100
one video made a hundred thousand
dollars joey [ __ ] salads
so crazy he's a goofy guy but he's he's
pretty good looking up i remember
right huh yeah yeah but he's also
industrial like
he's a hustler yeah sivo it's not about
it's not about the
it's not always about the amount of work
right it's about the uh
quality work work smart not quality i
don't i don't
know the quality of your work sucks bro
no but you know what i mean like like
you you know efficiency
what i'm dying to know is like dude have
you ever done any videos and and
maybe you have but you know those dudes
that like pull up in a ferrari next to a
hot chick and they're just like a gold
digger prank
that are those real no no because i've
seen other people do it too and they
just like the point
and the girls are like me oh they're
fake yeah they're all
they have to be right and those guys are
1 billion
fake the cars are rented and
i specif i specifically hate the gold
digger pranks because
there's so many people that believe it
and it's just so
so tight
weirdos in the world because they watch
gold digger pranks and think the world
is actually like
good thank god it's not like that i mean
i believed it because i'm like
you know cause you're dumb that's
[Music]
no they're not it's not real you can
rest you can rest easy
they're all fake 100 of them i don't
think there's been a single real gold
digger prank
i think that that's probably about right
yeah so how long have you been married
now
been married let's see i got married 10
10 12 was our marriage date so
over so over eight years we've been
married
how long were you guys together before
you started farting in front of each
other
that's that's jumping to the conclusion
that they're farting in front of are you
farting
in front of each other yeah we [ __ ] we
should with the door open
at what point in the relationship does
that start right away or say this
question
no not definitely not right away i would
say well we were together for five years
before we got married
let me think here when did the farting
be i started farting freely with lux
about a year in
and she only just started farting freely
and dude she's tearing them
all over the place really i'm telling
you
probably a few years i would say
probably a few years yeah
i love it man i absolutely love it when
my girl farts really and then i i i
i haven't had like uh one where that it
like kicks you in the nose
yeah like if i even smelled it like i
wasn't even sure that i was smelling it
like uh so she's good at
keeping me away from from the real like
uh deadly ones
yeah i remember in the uh at one point
your relationship like you would
fart but you'd be like like why you
farted but now you're just like
yeah you used to used to cough to cover
up your farts now with coronavirus
you fart to cover up your cops
that's a good one take that on the road
that's a good thing it's not
you know does that work people really
cough to cover their farts like that's
not a real thing is it
i don't know i heard you do it
like you could definitely still hear the
fart and it just draws more attention to
it because you're fake coughing
it's like what yeah
so the podcast like your podcast is
[ __ ] massive
right like do you have more uh more of
an audience
on the youtube version of it or
on the audio only version like
youtube more youtube and that's that's
cumulative because in audio it lives on
spotify itunes like uh all these
different little
outlets yeah it's on all those places
but
the youtube views is way more because
it's like a video based podcast and
i think that's the biggest reason why i
think it's uh
i think we only get like 25 or maybe at
most fifty percent
on i don't know yeah twenty-five percent
of the total views from from
from the audio only okay so
so uh the now the podcast is [ __ ]
massive i mean you're like
you're rich as [ __ ] but uh yeah do i
need to say that again
there's there's uh you know like you're
it's a behemoth podcast
but is the the strongest revenue stream
for you the podcast the merch
the youtube adsense youtube adsense
like uh well there's i guess three
branches of earning there's like the ads
you get from the podcast
all right with sponsors which is which
is
um the most which is more than the
adsense
right and then there's the adsense but
they're both really great
uh sources of income and then there's
teddy fresh which is a
separate like you know we promote it
through the
podcast so they're symbiotic in that way
but uh but yeah so those are kind of
three independent sources of income
because the ads can come and go
the adsense can come and go but they're
not related to each other
and then teddy fresh lives totally
independently
but what was your question which one's
more yeah like uh
the priority of the revenue streams like
like the pie chart
one two three like what's up i would say
i would say right now it's like 50
[Music]
teddy fresh 25 percent
adds 25 percent adsense um okay
and there's a dude [ __ ] you what are we
doing wrong
ethan i'm sorry but i have to go pee
again steve's making us drink liquids
and so like you guys don't have to pee i
i will you i can't
dance keep going to the bathroom can we
talk about what doing are you gonna go
in the rv
is he going in the rv there's a bathroom
in the rv and it's very top secret
i gotta say thank you for being so
candid do you find that like where uh
like like where you're pretty
transparent you're open about how
successful you've been does that just
bring on a wave of haters
well you know everything is public
like so yeah i'm i don't know i try to
be transparent and
i think it's important to be transparent
and open i'm not going to pretend like
i'm poor
we were poor for a long long time or we
weren't making a lot of money but
you know when when um when [ __ ]
uh what's the name of this uh
variety has this offshoot called dirt
and these guys you know we tried so hard
not because not because we wanted to
uh mask our wealth but because we don't
want people to know where we live
because the reason we moved originally
is because people kept coming to our
house and [ __ ] with us and
swatting us calling the police and
saying there was a murder at her house
so the swat team shows up and
helicopters show up that happened to us
several times
jeez that's one thing i'm glad that i'm
not like
rich or popular enough to have to deal
with like
i don't want anyone [ __ ] knowing
where we live and i don't want anyone
[ __ ] coming to the house and like i'm
a really nice guy
and oh yeah except if you [ __ ] show
up at my house like
yeah yeah yeah yeah of course and so
that was the reason we moved so we got a
we got a trust we did everything right
to try to
uh hide the uh new address but like a
day after we moved in and this happened
to several of my other friends there's
this [ __ ] website
where they somehow they have to
illegally obtain it either they've got
someone who works in city hall
or they're paying off the realtors who
are involved
i don't know there's a lot of different
ways they can get this information but
they put out the address they put out
the pictures they put out the price
and you know it's fair use and it's like
it shows up on everybody's news feed
you know what i mean and um so there's
really no [ __ ] hiding it
so yeah it's fine though i don't mind
being transparent i'm happy to be
transparent
you know i want people to know what what
the i'm not trying to hide anything and
i think it's good
that people know what's going on in my
life i'm not you know
yeah do you have a bowling alley in your
house
i wish i did no it's not that big it's
not the white house
you've done you've done that a great
number of your posts on instagram
recently
have been of you in drag have people
been calling you uh
have they been criticizing you saying
that's somehow insensitive to
to anything no i don't think they were
i think people are not offended i think
they're just
annoyed with me i i like that
i like that whole day like how we
started and what it's like now like
there's a whole series yeah
i really enjoyed that well the back
story was on our podcast
i started this uh i do a weekly episode
with
trisha paytas called frenemies and it's
super fun and it's doing super well and
everybody loves it and
and so during we had like a halloween
month where every week we dressed up
and i was just going all out like when i
did uncle fester i shaved
my head and eyebrows that's what it was
i was like what happened to you dude
it was awesome it was so much fun and um
so there was a lot of drag so obviously
for some reason there was just a lot of
drag
but it was fun and people really there
were some people got really mad and i
thought that was great
i thought that was totally fine [ __ ]
hey man
well they go the comments would be like
you're not funny dude you've fallen off
and i'd be like
all right i you know i don't know what
what can i do for you dude
yeah your podcast with trisha is another
example of like
because you were initially sort of
making fun of her and like
uh she said doctors throw photos or
something and now you guys are our
friends or frenemies at least and you
have a podcast together
it's almost like when you get in a fight
with someone at a bar but then they like
they pick you up and you shake each
other's hand you
share a drink like there's sort of some
gentlemanliness to uh your approach to
these things
thank you for saying that i hope so i i
definitely can think that i
i can definitely come off like really
offen offensive at first but
you know with trisha i think she's even
a little different because
a lot of people trisha is very
controversial figure but
there's so much she has so many good
qualities too like she's super funny
she's super witty she's got this
enormous personality
and um every podcast we did together
after
our initial drama was just so much fun
and people responded so strongly to it
because
she's just this such a wonderful
character and that's why we made the
podcast together and now i do
hold her to be uh definitely a friend of
mine for sure at the very least she's a
really good friend of mine and
i love uh everything we've been doing
together which is just
it's like this totally unlikely couple
but for some reason we have this really
fun chemistry together
and um give yourself some credit too
because the common denominator
is all these people that you've
eviscerated
like you just have a lovely rapport with
on your podcast like uh
it's not just this this girl that you're
talking about there's been a bunch
you know were you like that in high
school like you just wreck people [ __ ]
and they just want to be friends with
you
[Laughter]
no no i wasn't i wasn't uh
i wasn't very confrontational or
anything like that in high school
i was a normal dude i think for the most
part
i was a gamer nice what were
everquest you ever heard of that [ __ ] i
was playing water polo
oh i played water polo in high school
did you
you grew up around here right in la i
grew up in ventura ventura
so it's very close to l.a so how's ela
that's that that's how you say right ela
not gila yeah
no you said it perfectly she's great
she's doing awesome you know she's
she's the creative director the ceo of
teddy fresh so she's got her hands full
she's busy all the time
we had so much fun man like when i met
you guys it was just
it was just a good old-fashioned blast
yeah
she's working a lot you know we've got
our son who's a year and a half
almost plans for another what's that
another kid plans for another kid oh
yeah yeah we're trying we're
we're always trying to [ __ ] have kids
i'm i am literally always trying to put
a baby in her
i did nice we've got the uh ovulation
kit
we are always testing the ovulation you
know
and i don't know i try to save this i
try to save my nut
up you know how it is sure dude i i got
a vasectomy
but i still trying to save my nut up how
does that work when you get a vasectomy
you're still not right
correct yeah the you've got the goo but
not the swimmers is it the same does it
look
different yeah it's the same looking goo
feels the same yeah how interesting
yeah yeah no no change in flavor
yeah that's a that's kind of a legit
question though isn't it like
i mean yeah it's absolutely legit
well [ __ ] hey man dude i uh i just
congratulations on
on all your success is there anything
that you want to promote of course your
podcast
steve o'nearly special yeah i'm here to
promote stevo on
stevo.com no not really you know
you know hd podcast teddy fresh you know
what time it is
yeah i mean dude calm i i have to tell
you that
for for the touring that i did went from
just grinding away on the road and then
after every single show doing
a meet and greet with the entire
audience that one of the most frequent
things
i get is like oh man dude i loved you on
age three or you know
what's ethan like you know like it's uh
really oh
that's nice your uh your impact on
on culture is uh is is evident it's
it's real it's uh it's impressive man so
whatever well you know that podcast we
did together was was uh
it was a force i mean that that's one of
our most popular podcasts
even now it still gets like on a weekly
basis it's in like our top 10 most
viewed
that was a that was a legendary episode
man
that podcast bought him his house
[Music]
thank you i remember at that time i
totally spilled the beans
to ethan on his podcast about how i was
going to get
duct taped to the side of a truck and
driven down the highway all the way to
[ __ ] vegas wow
yeah it turned out to be kendra yeah you
know and i did that for the opening
sequence of
gnarly which is a multimedia comedy
special on stevo.com
did you say where you can get it from
yeah okay but yeah dude
did you did you really go duct tape the
whole way
i i did go all the way to vegas but what
we did was we mounted a uh
a box to the truck over me so that we
could
get through with impunity you know like
without uh
being pulled over and busted once we got
to the city before barstow we took the
box off
so i was just out in the wind like uh
wait you were covered by a box i'm
confused yeah i made it
to get out of la you're you were duct
taped but covered on it by a bomb yeah i
was duct taped to the truck
i was duct taped to the truck but then
they screwed uh like a coffin looking
plywood structure all over me
when when we were in colorado there's a
point where you see in the in the
opening sequence where you know we're in
the snow and it was so cold that night
that or that it's so cold that morning
that we had to take steve down right
away because he was shivering and
turning blue and
yeah loss of consciousness i remember
you going into the bath just like
oh
but i feel like the amount i have to say
the amount of suffering you went through
for that bit
i didn't really convey in the special
that's why people should buy it and
support
yeah yeah right because it was just a
bunch of cuts and when i saw it i was
like oh he probably got down
and went back up in colorado in colorado
i had to we filmed it on two days
there was the la to vegas and i was
taped to it the entire time
and then there was the the colorado day
where it was
up for shot in segments so did you ever
what did you do when you had to pee
i was wearing a diaper oh you just you
just did you ever did
you [ __ ] the diaper no [ __ ] no but i did
plenty of peeing well it's crazy that
you didn't [ __ ] the diaper because we
put x-lax in your eggs that morning
you didn't even mean it yeah he was too
charged up he was too excited yeah i
didn't [ __ ] care
did you do anything to pass the time or
were you just kind of excited to be on
the car
when the box was mounted on the inside
of the box i had my [ __ ] ipad up here
i had my
phone it was just like a little office
and i was getting
[ __ ] done doing emails and [ __ ] yeah big
time facetiming people
showing them where they're at yeah
dot com slash sale
where do we get teddy fresh teddy fresh
teddyfresh.com baby
all right well everybody support they
put a lot of money in that [ __ ] house
and uh we need a little we need a little
something to keep the house come on guys
let's keep the roof up and put a bowling
alley in there
come subs yeah i'm trying to build on a
bowling alley
yeah i wonder you guys yeah it's it's
really interesting man
and uh and [ __ ] nate dude i love you
ethan thank you for doing this with me
love you stevo thank you guys very nice
chatting with all you guys
likewise and um appreciate you all very
much keep up
keep doing your thing and god bless you
god bless you ethan
man could that have been any juicier
maybe but if it was someone might be
going to jail
dude i loved that love ethan and i
love you for hanging out until the very
end
man the very end dude
i feel like i should give you guys
something special for hanging out to the
very end
i'll tell you about the mug shot
glass
all right i've said enough thank you for
watching